bonjour interdit nu un bureau médical
comme n'importe quel autre mais ici il
ya une différence majeure
pour les patients comme sophie tardy
assument la totalité des coûts de leurs
consultations et elle parcourt les 300
km pour faire l'aller-retour entre laval
et son domicile en estrie parce que où
je suis flamand mais j'avais un temps
d'attentes pour rencontrer un
pneumologue fall et esthète souffle
c'est pour ça que j'ai cherché au privé
impunément lect ici elle a eu rendez
vous en moins de deux semaines en
pneumologie une rapidité qui a convaincu
son pneumologue de quitter le secteur
public en janvier j'étais pas
confortable avec l'idée avec la quantité
de patients qui attendaient sur des
listes d'attentes mois ultime ans j'ai
fini par faire le saut en grande partie
pour cette accessibilité là en
pneumologie 27000 requêtes sont en
attente au québec et le délai moyen
avant d'obtenir une consultation est de
322 jour un problème qu'on retrouve dans
plusieurs spécialités et qui amène
plusieurs médecins spécialistes a quitté
le secteur public
178 sont maintenant en passer au privé
une hausse de 55% depuis cinq ans
l'accès déficients dans le secteur
publique alimente la croissance du
secteur privé donc la deuxième bloc
opératoire gros médicale lacroix celui
de laval ici est en fonction depuis mars
lacroix médecine privée fait de la
chirurgie et offre des consultations
dans dix spécialités le groupe compte
maintenant 10 cliniques et environ 90
médecins appuyé par une centaine
d'autres professionnels la croissance
c'est exponentiel à chaque année la
demande est là pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée là on est à 150 mille visites
dans le groupe médicale lacroix par
année
l'expansion exige plus d espace et une
diversification des services offerts par
exemple en santé mentale semmaris
parkinson l'infirmière praticienne
spécialisée en santé mentale elle a
quitté le public pour le privé au
printemps incroyable les gens les gens
peuvent venir de chibougamau gatineau
baie comeau pour venir me consulter à
cause que l'attenté de huit mois pour
voir un psychiatre elle est déjà très
occupés forme de services en santé
mentale plusieurs sont prêts à payer
pour une évaluation initiale ces deux
ans 350 et 550 et pour les suivis de 100
$ en médecine familiale aussi le nombre
de médecins qui quittent le public
augmente comme la demande des patients
au privé à boucherville en montérégie on
compte maintenant quatre cliniques
privées peut-être parce qu environ le
quart de la population n'ont pas de
médecin de famille j'ai certains
patients qui sont venus qui étaient
bénéficiaires de l'aide sociale il faut
qu'ils ont vraiment commencé leur budget
pour pouvoir venir consulter pour
pouvoir avoir des soins plusieurs
patients décident parfois de payer après
avoir trop attendu combat des
pathologies qui on se dit mon dieu on
est au québec en 2022 c'est un peu drôle
que ça soit rendue jusque lors parce que
la personne avait juste pas de médecins
ici david gêne-t-il et radio canada
montréal